you
yeah many Americans will spend the 4th
of July barbecuing but for a growing
number traditional meat will not be on
the menu
in today's morning rounds we look at the
rising popularity and health effects of
plant-based meat impossible burger and
Beyond burger have exploded in
popularity the two alternative meat
brands are available in more than 40,000
restaurants now in grocery stores
combined dr. Tara Narula is at the table
we should note Tara comes from a house
divided husband eat meats meet our high
yeah I like your husband so what's in
this in this meat well this is so
interesting because actually these
companies are not necessarily catering
to people like me who are vegetarian but
to my husband those eat meat they want
us they do and so they're mimicking the
taste and the texture the chew the
sizzle and even the bleed so when you
compare the beyond burger for example an
impossible burger they're relatively
similar but they differ in kind of the
key components of their protein so
beyond burger uses a pea based protein
and possibly uses a soy-based protein
and then they both have mixtures of some
oils in them either canola oil or
coconut oil and interesting they also
you find the beyond burger in the meat
section there specifically putting it
there because they want to capture that
market can you capture the taste or
maybe you're not supposed to really
capture the taste let it be what it is
one of the differences between the two
is impossible burger claims that they
have found the reason that meat tastes
like meat and that's something called
heme so heme is an iron containing
molecule you may have heard of
hemoglobin or myoglobin all animals and
plants have it and they basically have
extracted this from the roots of soy
plants and then grown it in yeast and
then taking that heme and put it in
their burger and they're saying that
that mimics the flavor the aroma the th
one about not impossible okay so are
they healthy these plant-based burgers
are they healthy or healthier right so
that's really a great question and not
always so just because something says
it's plant-based doesn't mean it's
healthy so you do have to read the
labels when you look at the labels of
these two for example again they're
relatively similar in terms of calories
so about 250 calories 20 grams of
protein they have a fair amount of
sodium in them so that's
thing to note 400 milligrams and they
have a decent amount of saturated fat
again about six to eight mil eight
milligrams and the recommendation I'm
sorry grams is to have thirteen per day
so 68 is already a fair amount and then
they all have no cholesterol so you know
they are relatively healthy it's not
something you'd want to put in your diet
every single day but you can build it in
and we should say little known fact Tara
Narula and julio castro we're classmates
at Stanford Oh reunion in the green room
my freshmen door anything else no I know
they're happily married no that's the
point